hey what's up guys my name is jonah
welcome back to the game engine series
and in fact welcome to the game engine
series week
this is a week in which i'm live
streaming myself working on the game
engine series
all day every day for this entire week
from monday to friday
and then every day there'll be at least
one episode i don't think i'm going to
commit to two depending on how much work
we get done but
they'll basically be an episode of the
game industries coming out every day for
this entire week which is of course
pretty exciting now last time we were
doing i think the either the camera ui
or the sprite render
ui we're basically working on all of the
ui for all the different components
inside the hazelnut editor i'll have a
link up there so that you can check it
out
and today we're going to continue on
with that and finally be tackling
probably one of the hardest things that
we need to actually do at the moment
which is
the um the transform component ui
and to do the transform component ui
we're also going to discuss and possibly
rework some of the way that
transform components work in the first
place so let's go ahead and
jump on over into our code and take a
look at how everything is going to work
so first of all i just want to mention
that
we do have a roadmap it's
hazelengine.com roadmap there'll be a
link in the description below
and that contains uh basically the
roadmap of what it is we're doing
because obviously it's nice to both have
a plan for myself but also for the
community so that you guys have some
clarity
as to what it is that we're doing so our
current goal and this is kind of i guess
what we'll be doing this week as well
and working towards this week because we
will
finish the ui stuff probably i mean i'm
going to finish
probably writing all the ui stuff today
on the live stream
but the following episodes will probably
contain the rest of that
our goal is obviously to get a 2d
workflow up and running hazelnut ui
mvp is what we're working on at the
moment and as you can see we're up to
the transform component ui and then all
of this other stuff
i will probably plan and possibly even
record later today and you guys will see
it in the coming days
so uh that's what what that's what we're
working towards that's what the
previous episodes contained and now
we're up to the transom component ui so
what does that even mean
what does transform component ui mean so
the way that i like to
um kind of think about this is
i mean obviously for each of our
entities that we have we have a
transform
right at the moment we're just we've
just got the position which we can
easily modify like this
but we also want to have the rotation
and the scale
now what i'll do is i'll quickly open up
unity um because
it's really important i think to
actually uh you know when you're
developing a game engine to look at
another game engine
just like if you were you know
developing a game you would get ideas
from another game
um you know if you're working on any
kind of research you always look at
prior work and existing work and all
that stuff to see what else is out there
and how it's been done
so i basically have this kind of physics
test scene in unity
and if we take a look at for example
this cube here
um you know what does the transform
component look like what kind of data
does it need to hold now you can see
that i've set a crazy rotation here
for one which is like over 7000 here um
we've got like a position obviously xyz
i like that i like the fact that
um did someone just subscribe yeah thank
you sudaphone for subscribing during the
video
nice um it's always good uh
so as i was saying uh we want to have
xyz here so that is clearly kind of uh
you know separated into three different
um you know
uh i guess variables for both the
position or for the position rotation
and the scale right we have rotation in
degrees here
and then we have the scale now one thing
that i want you guys to pay attention to
here
is the rotation the rotation is seven
thousand
now at the moment the way that we're
actually storing our rotation
matrix or rather sorry the way that
we're actually storing our transform is
as a matrix
right so if we look at our components
and we take a look at the transform
component we just have a glm map for now
a glm mat 4
and specifically the rotation part of
that cannot store a rotation of 7000
because obviously if you think about a
rotation
a rotation of 0 degrees is the same as a
rotation of
360 degrees and the same as a rotation
of 720 degrees
so the point is that rotations kind of
wrap
and because of that it doesn't really
make sense like mathematically for us to
be storing like a rotation of 7000
because we could basically mod that
number of 7000 by 360 and it would be
equivalent
however us as humans when we're
developing like these games and maybe
for certain gameplay mechanics or
whatever
we might want to have a rotation that's
like a crazy high number
right so how can we do that well the
answer is we need to actually
store position rotation and scale
separately we don't want to store them
as a matrix even though it might make
sense for like rendering and other
kind of use cases to store it as a
matrix it's really probably not the best
thing to do
now the answer or one of the
considerations here is okay well how
does unity actually store this
right clearly we know that it can't
serialize a matrix because if it
serializes a matrix
then again it's not going to have a
rotation of 7000 it's going to be
whatever
that mod 360 potentially is and probably
sort of radians and we need to
decompose the matrix to get all that
stuff anyway so again
unity stores all of its scene files at
um
in like the yaml format right so it's
just text because that's the right way
to do things when you're
making a scene format for a level editor
because obviously if
multiple people are working on it you
want to be able to merge that together
if it's binary you can't do that
unless you have your own kind of inbuilt
like built-in tools and that's
obviously a mess so instead of all that
um let me quickly
uh try and find this so
if we grab this physics 2d test as an
example right
this is this physics 2d test that i've
created here we can actually look at the
dot unity file which is again just yaml
and we can take a look at how it
serializes all this data so we know that
we have i think that
that entity is called cube and it has a
bunch of components i believe this is
the transform component yes it is
and then you can see inside the
transform component we have
three different variables location local
rotation which
is a quaternion we have a local position
and we have a local scale
but then we've also got this local euler
angles hint and you can see that this is
what actually has that rotation of 7000
so my point is that unity actually
stores these separately
and that's also what we're going to be
doing inside hazel because
well we need to there's no real there's
no
it's not like if we do store it as a
matrix and we continue doing so that
introduces quite a lot of limitations
not just with this but with some other
stuff in the future as well and we can
obviously avoid that
by simply storing them separately and
then every time we actually need the
matrix we can just create the matrix
right
i mean we're actually doing that already
uh kind of if you look at the renderer
2d
then you'll see that we have
um like inside our draw rotated chord
function for example we take in a
position size rotation to draw a quad
and then
well we construct the matrix now
obviously we do have a function here
that doesn't do that and they can
already take in a matrix i imagine we're
using that to render with at the moment
but ultimately you know we can still
kind of render with this or construct
the matrix first
ourselves outside of the renderer 2d and
actually deal with that so that is what
we're going to be doing
um cool so the first step to doing that
is going to be
to go into the components and change the
way that our transform component works
so instead of having a transform we're
going to remove that we're going to have
a vec3
called translation which will just
initialize to zero by default
you could call this position i kind of
like the term translation it's just a
little bit more formal in 3d graphics
and
uh it you know might just seem a bit
better for applications outside of games
potentially
translation rotation and scale
i might change that in the future we'll
see what people think
and scale of course i'm going to
initialize to being just one um we're
going to probably we're going to get rid
of this
function instead we're going to take in
a translate we're going to make a
constructor that takes in a translation
just because i feel like
out of these three the one that you
probably want to set most often is the
translation
um and we'll do that and then
we'll get rid of these operators i will
actually add a function here called
glmat4 get transform const
now some people might be annoyed with me
doing this here
because it's a component it's just
supposed to be data only and like ah the
whole entity component system stuff
i don't care too much about things like
this because ultimately speaking
you know this function existing in this
struct or outside of the struct
doesn't really matter like
computationally it's just a function
you know um so it doesn't really matter
where you place it
in my opinion uh it's not like it's
going to slow down the performance of
this struct or anything right it's just
a function it can be outside of this
class it doesn't have to be a member
function
but then you'd also you'd need to take
in like the class and call it
differently
i just think for convenience obviously
in the way that you write the code it's
nice to have a function
that will take this data and create a
map4 out of it from within the transform
component just because
that's a very common use case so the way
that we're going to do this
um is uh we're basically going to return
glm translate and i think we'll need to
take in a header for that gtc
slash i think it's like matrix
transform.htpp
so translate glm map four um and then
we'll just take in this translation
pretty easy
we'll have to multiply that by the
rotation the way that i'm going to
construct the rotation here
is just using the separate axes so
i'll say glm rotate
um glm that 4 angle will be
so we'll for now we'll assume that it's
in radians
this is realistically something that you
probably want to think about because
um almost always we'll probably want to
refer to it as
degrees in terms of ui
but obviously when you're scripting you
might be working with like maybe
trigonomet trigonometry functions like
sine cosine you know tangent stuff like
that they obviously want radians so
on one hand radians is really useful on
one hand degrees is really
useful i think that maybe we'll
store radians here for now at least and
then we'll just convert to degrees and
back again for ui
um but that way maybe the script and
everything can still like if we you know
if we were to obtain this transform
component in the script
and access rotation it would already be
in radians so we could easily
you know pump that into like a sine
function or something like that
and we wouldn't need to worry about
converting it into radians first
um so this is obviously gonna be
rotation dot x
one zero zero oops
um and then we'll rotate uh on the y
this is going to be that
and then we're going to rotate on the
z-axis
so that's our rotation we can multiply
by rotation and then we will multiply
by the scale so scale um
glm not four
and this will just be scale i think
that's it okay translation rotation
scale and we have obviously the x y and
z rotation now we're not gonna really
need the x and y
rotation for uh the kind of 2d workflow
that we're working with but obviously
it is a transform component and you know
you should be able to you know rotate it
in the x and y axis regardless we're not
going to have two different transform
components for 2d or 3d
okay that looks pretty good to me i
think that's pretty much all i wanted to
do
now with these changes let's try and
compile everything because it's not
going to work and that way we'll be able
to see all the errors
and easily fix them so scene.cpp
okay so camera transform here we're
actually taking it as a pointer i guess
that's just to avoid the copy
um we're going to keep main camera as
the pointer but we'll
uh change this to just be a transform
like that
and then we'll simply just do um
transform.gettransform
to get the transform and calculate
transform from the transform component
uh we'll remove this uh this transform
again is just gonna be dot get
transform uh
we could obviously pump in the separate
um
you know because there is a draw quad
overload that takes in position rotation
scale like that
separately but we're not gonna bother
we'll just still use the matrix
uh what else did we have here seeing
hierarchy panel was upset
um yeah so this kind of stuff so
position
uh becomes um we'll get the transform
component which i'll call tc
and then we'll just do um
tc dot uh translation
let's compile everything again
i think there was okay um here we go
yeah so editor layer um had some issues
inside the camera controller as well
um yeah so this kind of stuff becomes
even easier so instead of like doing
weird you know matrix kind of you know
let's get the last column and
access the x uh um
the x thanks max scott for your
subscription
oh and pseudophone as well
thank you guys for your support i
appreciate it uh i was going to say that
yeah with with the kind of transform
stuff
um yeah instead of like accessing you
know the last column and the first kind
of
row of that which is the x uh
translation we can just you know
access the translation using english
words which is obviously a lot easier
because not everyone knows that the last
column you know
first uh first kind of field of that has
the actual x
translation so now we actually have dot
translation and then if you want to
modify
x well it's just translation.x so i like
the fact that this obviously makes it
even easier
in terms of api um obviously you know us
as potential software engineers we don't
really care like this makes sense to us
makes sense to me at least but you know
if you consider other people
using this game engine to make games who
maybe don't know how a game engine works
and how matrices work
obviously this is a lot easier for them
and that's always a win
unless you're trying to teach them how
things how things work and you're upset
because it's too easy
it's too easy to make a game with hazel
that sucks
um all right so translation x
translation x and this is obviously
translation
y so everything should still work
obviously and we'll test it out in a
minute
let's hit f5 i think that should be the
rest of the errors
also you guys watching will notice that
um the chat is still on screen i've made
the chat
the chat sub only so if you guys are
twitch subscribers or you can redeem
some cherno points which you get by
owning by
watching the stream um that's that's
what i've done with the chat now just to
make the videos a little bit more
exciting for people on youtube to watch
uh okay uh so let's maybe put this here
um
yeah so basically no change right this
still works
which is exactly what you'd expect i
think we can still move around with wasd
and this moves the camera as you can see
here
everything still works the exact same
way um the only difference of course
is that um uh we're now actually storing
translation rotation and scale
separately okay so that's kind of like
phase one of this
um it's important for us to move our
translation rotation scale into being
separate and that's actually going to
help us a lot with rotation because
if we try and modify rotation we can
sometimes wind up with gimbal lock and
other problems
this should help with that we'll revisit
that in the future when we're
doing 3d stuff because right now it
doesn't really apply can't really get
gimbal lock with a single rotation
but um yeah that should help us out so
the next step's going to be
um to go into the um
let's see so we want to do the transform
ui stuff now so
i'm i was mostly inspired by looking at
unreal engine
uh which i can't get up and running on
this user account because it thinks it's
not installed because i usually use a
different user account for
not streaming basically they have
different colors
um and maybe i'll uh maybe just google
this unreal engine
for transform ui
this is someone's done like a little
case study um yeah here we go
i guess this works let's try and zoom in
i forgot google doesn't like you doing
that
um okay you know what we're gonna be
real creative i mean i'm sure you guys
might be able to see that but just in
case you can't i'm gonna
bring up my favorite thing which is the
magnifier and we're gonna look at this
okay that is horribly low resolution
but such a fail um let's try and open
this
i'm sure this will be better here okay
there we go
don't need the magnifier after all um so
yeah you can see that basically unreal
engine has
x y and z they actually have them
color-coded i really like that design i
think it looks really cool
um i i prefer that to what unity has
which we saw before which is just kind
of like
that so i want to make something like
this this was kind of my inspiration
now because making like a full-on you
know
ui kind of like this in i'm gui is
obviously something that's going to take
some time
i decided to do it kind of instead of
working trying to work it out in front
of you guys during this
this recording of an episode i did it
during the live stream and that's why
these live streams are pretty cool to
catch
on twitter tv slash the churno so i
basically spent
like i want to say several hours just
going through and tweaking all
everything and making it look nice and i
now have a diff
with everything i've done on my monitor
here that i'm essentially just going to
copy for you guys and obviously explain
the code along
the way as well because the alternative
would be me playing around with a little
ui code and
padding and all of this stuff for like
an hour which i don't think would be
fun to watch for anyone outside of a
live stream
so um let's
uh let's take a look at
uh what that's going to look like so um
first of all
uh if we go into our and it's probably
going to be a slightly long episode
because there's a lot of stuff to do so
basically what we want is translation
rotation scale and we want that kind of
color coding stuff and i've also
what i've also done in my kind of
version is if you click
if you click on the um if you actually
click on the
like x for example the red x or the y or
the z or whatever
it actually resets it back to what it's
supposed to be so for translation and
rotation
it resets it to zero and then for scale
it resets it to one
so that's pretty cool because it's
actually like a button itself that kind
of
um the actual kind of red x or the green
y or the blue set
so let's take a look at how we can do
that um
so basically at the moment we have a
drag float three
that's fine but we're actually going to
have to split them up
because we want to be able to have uh
three different controls on the same
line
for x y and z because they have to be
different they can't just have a drag
flow 3 because we need to have those
labels in between
i also want to move the label to the
left side at the moment you can see that
we've got
this label um on the right side here
position which
was never good i want to have it on the
left side and by the end of
um you know by the end of today
hopefully we're going to have a really
nice looking uh
transform component aside from the font
because the font is the
default i'm going font um i actually
added the better font on the live stream
but i've taken it away now
because we want to do it last i don't
know maybe maybe i'll lose my patience
and do it now but we'll see
okay so how do we do this well first of
all uh we need three of these
right i guess we'll write the first one
here but ultimately what i think i'll do
is i'll just write a function
called something like you know drawback
3 control
because we're going to be able to reuse
this i'll leave it static for now we
might move it into like a ui library
file or something in the future but
basically
we need three of these one for um
translation one for rotation and one for
scale so it makes sense to just have a
function and call it three times instead
this is going to take in a label
uh as well as the actual like vector
that we want to modify
i'm also going to take in a reset value
so this will be zero by default because
we like for example for the translation
and rotation we want to reset them back
to zero when we press the button
but for scale we want to reset it to one
not to zero so that way you can take in
a custom reset value
and then i'll also have this um
parameter here called column width which
you'll see
used but i'll set it to 100 by default
because this is basically going to be
the
width of the labels so lots of things
here and we probably won't even call
that but it'll just be an option in case
we want to reuse this in the future so
basically what we're going to do
is i am gui uh columns two
um and then we'll have to remember to
reset that back to one so we're gonna
have two columns
one for the label uh and that's how we
can get it to look like unities does
where it's kind of like you know
it's aligned essentially to the left
then we have a bunch of space
potentially
and then we have this kind of on the
other side instead of just basically
being straight after the label because
these labels are varying
lengths of course varying sizes um so
we'll have the columns here
uh i'll set the column width
set column width to so 0 and we'll set
the width to whatever the column width
is
it's going to set our first column to be
whatever width this is
kind of like a constant width so they're
all going going to be aligned no matter
the label length
and then finally i'll have text and this
will just be the label
c string um and then we'll go
i am gui next column so this is our
first column
and this is going to be the label as i
mentioned so
um and again i'm literally just copying
the diff because working this out live
would be a disaster
so next up we'll push multi items widths
what this is going to do is basically
set up the widths for those three
controls so we have three we'll have
three controls and three buttons
each modifying the x y and z value
of this vector3 that we're taking in
here
so we need to push the widths and the
way that i actually wrote this code
because we just we can just use well
three because there's going to be three
of them and then i'm going calc item
with the way that i actually did this
was uh during the live stream i'll give
a little bit of an
of insight although you can of course
watch the live stream if you're a
patreon
um or a twitch subscriber uh if you want
the complete picture but basically
as you saw before we use dragflow three
so i literally just went into dragfloat3
and i looked at the source code for that
widget
and i think this was like a drag
behavior or something
i don't know i don't know how i got to
the wrong spot there
drag behavior t this may have changed
actually since last time
because i i did just um merge some yeah
it's this
i looked at this and then uh i think
what this does at some point
is uh drag behavior t yeah i think
i think maybe this has been refactored
since last time
let me see if i can find it
logarithmic stuff
i'm not sure exactly where that was
but basically uh let me just see if i
can yeah it's been it's been rewritten
since i last pulled i think um or maybe
i'm just forgetting where it was but
basically
yeah here it is drag scalar and that's
it right so what this
is is for for the number of components
in the vector that you're trying to
modify so it might be like a vector of
x3 of x4 or whatever
it's going to basically just have a
normal drag scaler
right um which is what drag float calls
here i don't know how i didn't get there
in the first place but anyway
and then he sets it up by pushing multi
multi-item
widths right so this is basically what i
did i looked at how the drag float 3
worked because obviously it had three
controls laid out side by side
and i adapted some of that code you know
to have buttons in between and to look a
little bit better
and that's kind of what i'm that that's
where the inspiration came from and
that's also where the actual code came
from
so that's how that works now i think to
use this though you need to actually
include i'm gui internal
um because it's kind of like internal
widget code
uh okay cool so and then what i did was
and a lot of this stuff again is
stylistic so i did
push style var right and then uh this
was like the
uh item spacing um
where are you item spacing
i set this to zero because i wanted it
to be really tight
uh and then uh
i think i had to come up with a button
size so i
got the line height and this is actually
coming from
the global i am gui
so this is based on the font so we
basically get the font size
i think you can just get the current one
and get the cons the font size but i
wrote it like this um i'm going
style dot frame padding dot y times two
now
funny story like well this came from uh
internally as well when you actually i
think either use a button or something
this is how it calculates the line
height so this is actually from i'm
gui's code as well
i'm not gonna go spelunking through that
because this episode will be like an
hour long if i do but
this you know this kind of calculation
for line height also comes directly from
i'm gui
so this is not like some magic you know
code i just looked at how i am gooey
does certain things and now i'm making
my own widget that's essentially what's
happening here so the button size is
going to be
the line height this is the width of the
button
is going to be line height plus three so
i've decided to add like three pixels of
padding
um uh because that looks nice and then
line height for the height
uh and then now we basically need to set
up the button
but instead of and i'll just do the
button kind of without the colors first
just so that we see what that looks like
so for example we have an x button
um we'll use button size for the button
and then if it's pressed we obviously
want to reset the values
to whatever the uh reset value is
just like that right um and then
uh that's kind of that's done for this
button
now we want to call i'm going same line
because well everything's going to be on
the same line obviously
and then we're going to be using i am
gui drag float
now we don't want a label because we've
already provided a label actually the
button itself is
label so we'll just use this hash and
then x because we still need to provide
it with some kind of id
if you put a hash hash out the front
this won't show up as a label if you
just leave x it'll actually
render x as well you probably can use
now you do need a label here you can't
just use like a numeric id or anything
like that
so uh this is now obviously just going
to be values x
um and then the kind of speed i guess
we'll just leave it 0.1 for now
and then um we need to do pop item with
because we've pushed three widths this
is going to pop the first one
and then again same line so this
what what you see here uh is essentially
all we need we just need three of these
right so for x for y
and for z so this is going to be the y
one
um and this is going to be the z one
is is that
okay i think that is pretty much it
um
[Music]
uh and then at the
i guess we don't probably don't need a
same line at the very end we can just go
back to
using columns one and i think that's it
so that's the basics of this
let's go ahead and try and draw this
we'll see what we end up with
so i'll just do drawback three control
this is going to be
um so the label will call this
translation this is going to be
tc dot translation
reset value will leave a zero column
with we'll leave it default as well
let's see what on earth this looks like
because i probably butchered some stuff
because i didn't copy everything down
because
i wanted to make it a little bit more
simple as a first pass
um okay it just crashed great let's see
what we did wrong probably just missing
like a
style modifiers we didn't pop the item
spacing
so i think i think this style var
is supposed to um basically how long is
that
how long is that supposed to be around
for i think until the very end yeah
so we can just pop it here
there we go
but this is this is mostly correct i
think i think the only the big thing
here
yeah so if we look at this oh thank you
uh
for the prime subscription potionator
um i think that this uh
yeah this looks pretty good right so
it's a little bit tight obviously like
if we if it's that small but there we go
we have x y
and z here we should be able to move
everything as usual we just don't have
the beautiful colors
and you can also see that it resets
beautiful right and we have translation
on the left side with a little kind of
column thing here which we can actually
kind of move as well
so pretty cool um
[Music]
now let's let's kind of maybe fill in
the colors and do the rest right
so and that's really going to make it
look nice so
before we do the button let's push some
style colors for the button now
obviously this also took a little bit of
time for me to tweak the colors to make
them to look
right and to look nice and what i
consider nice at least
so if we do push style color uh the
first color we'll be setting
is the button color itself so there's
three button colors there's
the normal button which is just what the
button looks like if you're not
interacting with it
there's a hovered color for if you put
your mouse over the button but you don't
click and then there's an active color
for what when you're kind of clicked on
it
so when you press the mouse button but
you haven't let go yet so
um for this this is obviously the x so
it should be red
i've set it to 0.8
0.1 and 0.15
um and is that
oh well we also need the alpha color
right
so then we have button hovered
and we also have a button active
so for the hovered i basically just made
it a little bit brighter so i think i
use 0.9 0.2
and 0.2 and then for the
active i basically just made it the same
as the normal button because i didn't
want like a billion different colors
so if you press it it goes back to being
the normal color
and then finally we need to pop these
because obviously they have to be
different for the other buttons
and you can just do pop style color pop
style color actually
also takes in a parameter here you can
just pop all three at once with one line
of code which of course
is nice um now
button y and button z will do the same
thing for
obviously with different colors
uh so let's do them here
you can see why i wanted to make this a
function lots of code here and again
we'll probably
end up moving this into some kind of
ui library in general because i imagine
we'll use this for a lot of different
components and probably just outside the
scene hierarchy panel in general as well
that's why i've kind of written it as a
free floating function so this is going
to be green
green is of course like the most the
brightest color i guess or the most
lumos i don't know what the
i don't know i don't know what the right
term is but green is obviously very
visible on the spectrum which is why
you did generally want it a little bit
darker that makes sense
as to why these values are slightly
darker than they were for red it's
not just like a direct copy but
different here
um so these are obviously this should be
the
same so it should be 0.2 so 0.2.7.2 and
then 0.3.8.3
a little bit brighter for the hover
again and then finally for the blue
button
i didn't really want it to look like
purple so i used very little red here
and then
25 for green and then finally for red
itself we have eight
and then obviously these are identical
here
and as for this it just goes up by one
basically so three five
and point nine okay let's take a look at
these colors now they should look
very beautiful i imagine they do
right a little bit squishy here um we
can just should be
dragged a little bit more i think out um
and we probably don't need to three
decimal places here
especially if we're doing by point one
what does unity do
so unity has it to i guess it depends on
what the number is
so you can see it kind of goes to a
small number here but then if you have
it wider
um then or if you have it like set to
something with three decimal places it
has that so
we could potentially have that as well
it doesn't really matter
okay cool so that's our translation
let's do rotation scale which of course
should be
very easy to do so if we go back to
this rotation
and scale so rotation is
uh rotation scale scale the only thing
that the scale needs is the reset value
set to 1
instead of 0 because of course we don't
want to reset the scale to 0
because we won't see anything if we do
that um
so now there you go
right we've got translation rotation
scale looks lovely we've got our
beautiful colors here
we can rotate stuff oh right this brings
me to my next point
at the moment if we try and move one of
these they're all tied
right why are they all tied they're all
tied because they have the exact same
identifier
they're all known as x y and z now if
you're doing this manually you could
easily fix this by adding more kind of
you know unique data here for it so for
example this might be the translation x
that might be the rotation y or whatever
but i'm guilty also lets you push an id
and pop an id
which basically means that the next
group belongs to a particular namespace
you could say
so uh i'm going push id
we can use that for this whole control
and just to keep it simple i'm just
going to take the label
right so whatever so basically this
means that in a particular group at
least
you know maybe with other ids that
you've pushed you need to make sure that
each
vec3 control has a unique label if you
you know don't want that then you can
probably refactor this code to do
something else
that's it push id pop id for that label
let's hit f5 and now everything should
work independently
which is what you would expect so uh
let's
um go to red square and let's try and
translate it
yep we can translate it we can translate
on the z axis which
goes out of the camera clip um the
rotation on the x-axis bit weird but we
can do that rotation
on the z-axis is what we want now hold
on a minute
i want this to be in degrees not radians
because it's a bit annoying if it's in
radians so we'll have to fix that up
and finally you can see scale works as
well and i can easily reset that back to
one and reset these
just by clicking on them which is really
cool okay i really like this control i
think it's nice
um so the last thing is how do we get
rotation in degrees well since we've
decided
since we've decided that it's up to the
client because the component itself
stoles it in radians
we basically need to get the rotation
and copy it like that and just chuck a
little
glm degrees here to convert it to
degrees
we pass in that and then we could have
optionally a boolean that's returned
if it changes um that way we don't have
to do it all the time but i don't it's
not a big deal obviously to convert from
radiance to degrees
so i'll just do it anyway we just set tc
rotation
back to rotation dot or rather glm
radians rotation just like that
okay and uh now our rotation should be
in degrees for our ui
right so if i look at the red square and
i'll move it a little bit
uh let's see our uh rotation
yeah you can see that it's now in
degrees if i set it to like 45 or
something
then you can see it's obviously at a 45
degree angle that's
it okay that is how that works now i
wonder if
um it's easy because i don't like the
fact that it's i want to make it to two
decimal places and set it to three i
think it's a bit noisy
and i didn't do this on my live stream
so let's see if we can work this out
live
here now so if i um
so obviously the thing is doing that is
the drag float
so i wonder if there's yeah there is a
parameter called format right so i'm
sure that if i
uh we need a min and max which what's
the default on that
the default is zero and zero so we can
leave them as zero so that we don't have
any min and max because i don't want a
minute max
and then formats let's look at the
default format because that will also
help us write this
so the default format is just yeah what
i thought it was same as like for printf
or sprintf or whatever
this is the default format we can just
change it to be
point two f instead of point three f uh
and then of course
we're going to and they have it to two
decimal places
let's add these to the rest of the drag
floats whoops
and now it should look a little bit
cleaner you can have it to one or you
can have it to
you know something else but i added it
twice
nice one um but i think
that uh two decimal places is pretty
reasonable now in
all seriousness though if you want to
specify a really specific number you
should probably
like maybe it's not good to clamp it to
a you know
maybe you should see what the number is
first um and then decide because
obviously if i want to have 0.0001
i can set it to that but it only appears
as zero which is useless right
so this might not be something that you
necessarily want um
but uh you know we'll we'll cross that
bridge when we get there
anyway i think this looks pretty nice um
you can see here
and uh yeah we have the nice labels
aligned on this side
and everything else should work as
expected
so that is the transform component done
now let's go ahead and
and cross that off it's very satisfying
next up and next episode we'll look at
adding
and removing entities right so we should
be able to add a new entity
um and then also add new components to
that entity so we can basically start
creating scenes and all that stuff
from what we've got so that is that hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please don't forget to hit the like
button
or if you're on twitch you can subscribe
to support the stream or follow
um also patreon.com is best way to help
support this series and
you'll get access to all the past
livestreams as well as dev which is like
the more advanced 3d
c-sharp scripting kind of version of
hazel that has most of this stuff done
already
thank you guys for watching i will see
you next time goodbye
[Music]
you